who do you think is the most powerful
man on the planet Black Rock State
Street and Vanguard these three
companies are the largest shareholders
of 88% of S&P 500 companies you know how
much total money there is in the world
circulating it's around $430 trillion
$440 trillion they control $66 trillion
of the entire world's wealth so the
commanderin-chief is not who we think it
is it's the CEO of Black Rock Vanguard
State Street it's people like Barry Fink
and George Soros they have influence
we've always been like is it good for a
guy like Elon Musk to be as rich as he
is Elon Musk is nothing compared to what
these guys are doing collectively
together